The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: This is
the one and only review, you
could say, of linear algebra.
I just think linear
algebra is very important.
You may have got that idea.
And my website even has a little
essay called Too Much Calculus.
Because I think it's crazy
for all the U.S. universities
do this pretty much,
you get semester
after semester in differential
calculus, integral calculus,
ultimately
differential equations.
You run out of steam
before the good stuff,
before you run out of time.
And anybody who computes,
who's living in the real world,
is using linear algebra.
You're taking a
differential equation,
you're taking your
model, making it discrete
and computing with matrices.
The world's digital
now, not analog.
I hope it's okay to start the
course with linear algebra.
But many engineering
curricula don't fully
recognize that and
so if you haven't
had an official course, linear
algebra, stay with 18.085.
This is a good way to learn it.
You're sort of learning
what's important.
So my review would be-- And
then this is-- Future Wednesdays
will be in our regular
room for homework, review,
questions of all kinds,
and today questions too.
Shall I just fire away for
the first half of the time
to give you a sense of
how I see the subject,
or at least within
that limited time.
And then questions
are totally welcome.
Always welcome, actually.
Right?
So I'll just start right up.
So essentially linear
algebra progresses
starting with vectors to
matrices and then finally
to subspaces.
So that's, like,
the abstraction.
You could say abstraction,
but it's not difficult,
that you want to see.
Until you see the
idea of a subspace,
you haven't really
got linear algebra.
Okay, so I'll start
at the beginning.
What do you do with vectors?
Answer: you take their
linear combinations.
That's what you can
do with a vector.
You can multiply it by a number
and you can add or subtract.
So that's the key operation.
Suppose I have
vectors u, v and w.
Let me take three of them.
So I can take
their combinations.
So some combination will
be, say some number times
u plus some number times v
plus some number times w.
So these numbers
are called scalars.
So these would be
called scalars.
And the whole thing is
a linear combination.
Let me abbreviate those
words, linear combination.
And you get some answer, say b.
But let's put it down, make
this whole discussion specific.
Yeah, I started a
little early, I think.
I'm going to take three
vectors, u, v and w,
and take their combinations.
They're carefully chosen.
My u is going to be [1, -1, 0].
And I'll take vectors
in three dimensions.
So that means their combinations
will be in three dimensions,
R^3, three-dimensional space.
So that'll be u and then
v, let's take 0, I think,
1 and -1.
Okay.
Suppose I stopped there and
took their linear combinations.
It's very helpful
to see a picture
in three-dimensional space.
I mean the great thing
about linear algebra,
it moves into
n-dimensional space,
10-dimensional, 100-dimensional,
where we can't visualize,
but yet, our instinct is
right if we just follow.
So what's your instinct if
I took those two vectors,
and notice they're
not on the same line,
one isn't a multiple
of the other,
they go in different directions.
If I took their combinations,
say x_1*u + x_2*v. Oh now,
let me push, this is
a serious question.
If I took all
their combinations.
So let me try to
draw a little bit.
Okay.
I'm in three-dimensional
space and u goes somewhere,
maybe there and v goes
somewhere, maybe here.
Now suppose I take
all the combinations,
so I could multiply
that first guy
by any number, that
would fill the line.
I can multiply that second
guy, v. So this was u
and this was v. I can multiply
that by any number x_2, that
would fill its line.
Each of those
lines I would later
call a one-dimensional
subspace, just a line.
But now, what happens if I take
all combinations of the two?
What do you think?
You got a plane.
Get a plane.
If I take anything on this
line and anything on this line
and add them up you can see
that I'm not going to fill 3-D.
But I'm going to fill
a plane and that maybe
takes a little thinking.
It just, then it
becomes sort of,
you see that that's
what it has to be.
Okay, now I'm going to
have a third vector.
Okay, my third vector
will be [0, 0, 1].
Okay, so that [0, 0, 1]
is 0 in the x, 0 in the y
and 1 in the z direction.
So there's w.
Now I want to take
their combinations.
So let me do that
very specifically.
How do I take combinations?
This is important.
Seems it's very
simple, but important.
I like to think of taking the
combinations of some vectors,
I'm always putting vectors
into the columns of a matrix.
So now I'm going to move
to step two: matrix.
I'm going to move to step
two and maybe I'll put it--
well no, I better put it here.
Okay, step two is the matrix has
those vectors in its columns.
So in this case,
it's three by three.
That's my matrix and
I'm going to call it A.
How do I take
combinations of vectors?
I should have maybe
done it in detail here,
but I'll just do it
with a matrix here.
Watch this now.
If I multiply A by the vector
of x's, what that does,
so this is now A times
x, so very important,
a matrix times a vector.
What does it do?
The output is just what I want.
This is the output.
It takes x_1 times
the first column
plus x_2 times the second
plus x_3 times the third.
That's the way matrix
multiplication works,
by columns.
And you don't always see that.
Because what do you see?
You probably know how
to multiply that matrix
by that vector.
Let me ask you to do it.
What do you get?
So everybody does it
a component at a time.
So what's the first component
of the answer? x_1, yeah.
How do you get that?
It's row times the vector.
And when I say "times", I
really mean that dot product.
This plus this plus this is x_1.
And what about the second row?
-x_1 + x_2.
Or I'll just say x_2 - x_1.
And the third guy,
the third component
would be x_3 - x_2, right?
So right away I'm
going to say, I'm
going to call this matrix
A a difference matrix.
It always helps to
give names to things.
So this A is a difference matrix
because it takes differences
of the x's.
And I would even say a
first difference matrix
because it's just the
straightforward difference
and we'll see second
differences in class Friday.
So that's what A does.
But you remember
my first point was
that when a matrix
multiplies a vector,
the result is a
combination of the columns.
And that's not always, because
see, I'm looking at the picture
not just by numbers.
You know, with numbers
I'm just doing this stuff.
But now I'm stepping
back a little bit
and saying I'm combining.
It's this vector times x_1.
That vector times x_1 plus
this vector times x_2 plus that
one times x_3 added
together gives me this.
Saying nothing complicated here.
It's just look at
it by vectors, also.
It's a little
interesting, already.
Here we multiplied these vectors
by numbers. x_1, x_2, x_3.
That was our thinking here.
Now our thinking
here is a little--
we've switched slightly.
Now I'm multiplying the
matrix times the numbers in x.
Just a slight switch, multiply
the matrix times the number.
And I get some answer, b.
Which is this, this is b.
And of course, I can do
a specific example like,
suppose I take, well, I could
take the squares to be in x.
So suppose I take A times the
first three squares, [1, 4, 9].
What answer would I get?
Just to keep it clear that
we're very specific here.
So what would be the output be?
I think of this as the input,
the [1, 4, 9], the x's.
Now the machine is multiply
by A and here's the output.
And what would be the output?
What numbers am I
going to get there?
Yeah?
One, three,
something? [1, 3,  5].
Which is actually a
little neat that you
find the differences of the
squares are the odd numbers.
That appealed to me
in school somehow.
That was already
a bad sign, right?
This dumb kid notices that you
take differences of squares
and get odd numbers, whatever.
So now is a big step.
This was the forward
direction, right?
Input, and there's the output.
But now the real reality--
That's easy and important,
but the more deep
problem is, what
if I give you b and ask for x?
So again, we're switching
the direction here.
We're solving an equation now,
or three equations and three
unknowns, Ax=b.
So if I give you this
b, can you get x?
How do you solve
three equations?
We're looking backwards.
Now that won't be too hard
for this particular matrix
that I chose; because
it's triangular,
we'll be able to go backwards.
So let me do that.
Let me take b to
be-- It's a vector,
it's got three components.
And now I'm going to
go backwards to find x.
Or we will.
So do you see the
three equations?
Here they are: x_1 is b_1, this
is b_2, that difference is b_3.
Those are my three equations.
Three unknown x's, three
known right-hand sides.
Or I think of it as A
times x, as a matrix
times x giving a vector b.
What's the answer?
As I said, we're going
to be able to do this.
We're going to be able to solve
this system easily because it's
already triangular.
And it's actually
lower triangular
so that means we'll
start from the top.
So the answers, the
solution will be what?
Let's make room for it. x_1,
x_2, and x_3 I want to find.
And what's the answer?
Can we just go from
top to bottom now?
What's x_1? b_1, great.
What's x_2?
So x_2 - x_1.
These are my equations.
So what's x_2 - x_1?
Well, it's b_2, so what
is x_2? b_1 + b_2, right?
And what's x_3?
What do we need there for x_3?
So I'm looking at
the third equation.
That'll determine x_3.
When I see it this
way, I see those ones
and I see it multiplying x_3.
And what do I get?
Yeah, so x_3 minus
this guy is b_3,
so I have to add in
another b_3, right?
I'm doing sort of
substitution down as I go.
Once I learned that x_1 was b_1
I used it there to find x_2.
And now I'll use
x_2 to find x_3.
And what do I get again? x_3
is, I'll put the x_2 over there.
I think you've got
it. b_1 + b_2 + b_3.
So that's the solution.
Not difficult because the
matrix was triangular.
But let's think
about that solution.
That solution is
a matrix times b.
When you look at that-- So
this is like a good early step
in linear algebra.
When I look at that I see
a matrix multiplying b.
You take that step up
to seeing a matrix.
And you can just read it off.
So let me say, what's the
matrix there that's multiplying
b to give that answer?
Remember the columns
of this matrix-- well,
I don't know how you
want to read it off.
But one way is, the think
the columns of that matrix
are multiplying b_1, b_2,
and b_3 to give this.
So what's the first
column of the matrix?
It's whatever I'm reading
off, the coefficients, really,
of b_1 here: [1, 1, 1].
And what's the second column
of the matrix? [0, 1, 1].
Good.
Zero b_2's, one, one.
And the third is? [0, 0, 1].
Good.
Now, so lots of things
to comment here.
Let me write up again
here, this is x.
That was the answer.
It's a matrix times b.
And what's the name
of that matrix?
It's the inverse matrix.
If Ax gives b,
the inverse matrix
does it the other way
around, x is A inverse b.
Let me just put that over here.
If Ax is b, then x
should be A inverse b.
So we had inverse, I wrote
down inverse this morning
but without saying the point,
but so you see how that comes?
I mean, if I want
to go formally,
I multiply both
sides by A inverse.
If there is an A inverse.
That's a critical
thing as we saw.
Is the matrix invertible?
The answer here is, yes,
there is an inverse.
And what does that really mean?
The inverse is the thing that
takes us from b back to x.
Think of A as kind of
a-- multiplying by A
is kind of a mapping,
mathematicians use the word,
or transform.
Transform would be good.
Transform from x to b.
And this is the
inverse transform.
So it doesn't happen to
be the discrete Fourier
transform or a wavelet
transform, it's a-- well,
actually we could
give it a name.
This is kind of a
difference transform, right?
That's what A did,
took differences.
So what does A inverse do?
It takes sums.
That's why you see 1, 1
and 1, 1, 1 along the rows
because it's just
adding, and you see it
here in fully display.
It's a sum matrix.
I might as well
call it S for sum.
So that matrix, that sum
matrix is the inverse
of the different matrix.
And maybe, since I hit
on calculus earlier,
you could say that
calculus is all about one
thing and its inverse.
The derivative is
A, and what's S?
In calculus.
The integral.
The whole subject is
about one operation,
now admittedly
it's not a matrix,
it operates on functions
instead of just little vectors,
but that's the main point.
The fundamental
theorem of calculus
is telling us that integration's
the inverse of differentiation.
So this is good and if
I put in b = [1, 3, 5]
for example just to
put in some numbers,
if I put in b = [1, 3, 5], what
would the x that comes out be?
[1, 4, 9].
Right?
Because it takes us back.
Here, previously we started, we
took differences of [1, 4, 9],
got [1, 3, 5].
Now if we take sums of
[1, 3,  5], we get [1, 4, 9].
Now we have a system
of linear equations.
Now I want to step
back and see what
was good about this matrix.
Somehow it has an inverse.
Ax=b has a solution,
in other words.
And it has only one
solution, right?
Because we worked it out.
We had no choice.
That was it.
So there's just one solution.
There's always one
and only one solution.
It's like a perfect
transform from the x's
to the b's and back again.
Yeah so that's what an
invertible matrix is.
It's a perfect map from one
set of x's to the x's and you
can get back again.
Questions always.
Now I think I'm ready
for another example.
There are only two examples.
And actually these two examples
are on the 18.06 web page.
If some people asked
after class how
to get sort of a review
of linear algebra,
well the 18.06 website would
be definitely a possibility.
Well, I'll put down the
OpenCourseWare website, mit.edu
and then you would look
at the linear algebra
course or the math one.
What is it?
web.math.edu, is that it?
No, maybe that's an
MIT-- so is it math?
I can't live without
edu at the end, right?
Is it just edu?
Whatever!
So that website has, well, all
the old exams you could ever
want if you wanted any.
And it has this
example and you click
on Starting With Two Matrices.
And this is one of them.
Okay, ready for the other.
So here comes the second
matrix, second example
that you can contrast.
Second example is going
to have the same u.
Let me put-- our matrix,
I'm going to call it,
what am I going to call it?
Maybe C. So it'll
have the same u.
And the same v. But
I'm going to change w.
And that's going to
make all the difference.
My w, I'm going to
make that into w.
So now I have three vectors.
I can take their combinations.
I can look at the
equation Cx=b .
I can try to solve it.
All the normal stuff
with those combinations
of those three vectors.
And we'll see a difference.
So now, what happens
if I do-- Could
I even like do just a little
erase to deal with C now?
How does C differ?
If I change this
multiplication from A
to C, to this new matrix.
Then what we've done is to put
in a minus one there, right?
That's the only change we made.
And what's the change in Cx?
I've changed the
first row, so I'm
going to change the first row of
the answer to what? x_1 - x_3.
You could say again,
as I said this morning,
you've sort of changed the
boundary condition maybe.
You've made this difference
equation somehow circular.
That's why I'm
using that letter C.
Is it different?
Ah, yes!
I didn't get it right here.
Thank you, thank you very much.
Absolutely.
I mean that would have been
another matrix that we could
think about but it
wouldn't have made
the point I wanted, so thanks,
that's absolutely great.
So now it's correct
here and this is correct
and I can look at equations
but can I solve them?
Can I solve them?
And you're guessing
already, no we can't do it.
Right?
So now let me maybe
go to a board, work
below, because I'd hate to
erase, that was so great,
that being able to solve
it in a nice clear solution
and some matrix coming in.
But now, how about this one?
Okay.
One comment I should
have made here.
Suppose the b's were zero.
Suppose I was looking
at, originally
at A times x equal
all zeroes, What's x?
If all the b's
were zero in this,
this was the one that dealt with
the matrix A. If all the b's
are zero then the x's are zero.
The only way to get
zero right-hand sides,
b's, was to have zero x's.
Right?
If you wanted to get zero
out, you had to put zero in.
Well, you can always put
zero in and get zero out,
but here you can put other
vectors in and get zero out.
So I want to say there's
a solution with zeroes
out, coming out of C, but
some non-zeroes going in.
And of course we know
from this morning
that that's a signal that it's
a different sort of matrix,
there won't be an inverse,
we've got questions.
Tell me all the solutions.
All the solutions, so actually
not just one, well you could
tell me one, tell me one first.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: [1, 1, 1].
Okay.
Now tell me all.
AUDIENCE: C, C, C.
PROFESSOR STRANG: [C, C, C].
Yeah.
That whole line
through [1, 1,  1].
And that would be normal.
So this is a line of solutions.
Right.
A line of a solutions.
I think of [1, 1, 1] as in some
solution space, and then all
multiples.
That whole line.
Later I would say
it's a subspace.
When I say what that
word subspace means
it's just this--
linear algebra's
done its job beyond
just [1, 1,  1].
Okay.
So, again, it's this
fact of-- if we only
know the differences-- Yeah.
You can see different ways
that this has got problems.
So that's C times x.
Now one way to see
a problem is to say
we can get the answer of all
zeroes by putting constants.
All that's saying in
words the differences
of a constant factor
are all zeroes, right?
That's all that happened.
Another way to see a problem if
I had this system of equations,
how would you see that
there's a problem,
and how would you see that
there is sometimes an answer
and even decide when?
I don't know if you
can take a quick look.
If I had three equations,
x_1-x_3 is b_1,
this equals b_2,
this equals b_3.
Do you see something that I
can do to the left sides that's
important somehow?
Suppose I add those
left-hand sides.
What do I get?
And I'm allowed
to do that, right?
If I've got three equations
I'm allowed to add them,
and I would get zero, if I
add, I get zero equals --
I have to add the right-sides
of course -- b_1+b_2+b_3.
I hesitate to say a fourth
equation because it's not
independent of those
three, but it's
a consequence of those three.
So actually this is telling
me when I could get an answer
and when I couldn't.
If I get zero on
the left side I have
to have zero on the
right side or I'm lost.
So I could actually solve
this when b_1+b_2+b_3=0.
So I've taken a step there.
I've said that okay,
we're in trouble often,
but in case the right-side
adds up to zero then we're not.
And if you'll allow me to
jump to a mechanical meaning
of this, if these were
springs or something, masses,
and these were forces on
them -- so I'm solving
for displacements of masses
that we'll see very soon,
and these are forces -- what
that equation is saying is,
because they're sorta cyclical,
it's somehow saying that
if the forces add up to zero,
if the resulting force is zero,
then you're okay.
The springs and masses don't
like take off, or start
spinning or whatever.
So there's a physical
meaning for that condition
that it's okay provided,
if, the b's add up to zero.
But of course, if the b's don't
add up to zero we're lost.
Right yeah.
Okay.
So Cx=b could be solved
sometimes, but not always.
The difficulty with C is
showing up several ways.
It's showing up in C times
a vector x giving zero.
That's bad news.
Because no C inverse
can bring you back.
I mean it's like you
can't come back from zero.
Once you get to zero, C inverse
can never bring you back
to x, right?
A took x into b up there, and
then A inverse brought back x.
But here there's no
way to bring back
that x because I can't
multiply zero by anything
and get back to x.
So that's why I see
it's got troubles here.
Here I see it's got troubles
because if I add the left sides
I get zero.
And therefore the right
sides must add to zero.
So you've got
trouble several ways.
Ah, let's see another way,
let's see geometrically
why were in trouble.
Okay, so let me draw a picture
to go with that picture.
So there's
three-dimensional space.
I didn't change u,
I didn't change v,
but I changed w to minus
one, what does that mean?
Minus one sort of going
this way maybe, zero,
one is the z direction,
somehow I changed it to there.
So this is w star
maybe, a different w.
This is the w that
gave me problems.
What's the problem?
How does the picture
show the problem?
What's the problem with those
three vectors, those three
columns of C?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: There
in the same plane.
There in the same plane.
w* gave us nothing new.
We had the combinations
of u and v made a plane,
and w* happened to
fall in that plane.
So this is a plane
here somehow, and goes
through the origin of course.
What is that plane?
This is all combinations,
all combinations of u, v,
and the third guy, w*.
Right.
It's a plane, and
I drew a triangle,
but of course, I should draw
the plane goes out to infinity.
But the point is there
are lots of b's, lots
of right-hand sides
not on that plane.
Okay.
Now if I drew all combinations
of u, v, w, the original w,
what have I got?
So let me bring that
picture back for a moment.
If I took all
combinations of those
does w lie in the
plane of u and v?
No, right?
I would call it independent.
These three vectors
are independent.
These three, u, v, and w*
I would call dependent.
Because the third guy was a
combination of the first two.
Okay, so tell me
what do I get now?
So now you're really
up to 3-D. What
do you get if you take all
combinations of u, v, and w?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR STRANG: Say it again.
The whole space.
If taking all
combinations of u, v, w
will give you the whole space.
Why is that?
Well we just showed--
when it was A we
showed that we
could get every b.
We wanted the combination
that gave b and we found it.
So in the beginning when we
were working with u, v, w,
we found -- and this
was short hand here --
this said find a
combination to give b,
and this says that
combination will work.
And we wrote out what x was.
Now what's the
difference-- Okay, here.
So those were dependent,
sorry, those were independent.
I would even call those
three vectors a basis
for three-dimensional space.
That word "basis" is a big deal.
So a basis for
five-dimensional space
is five vectors that
are independent.
That's one way to say it.
The second way to say it
would be their combinations
give the whole
five-dimensional space.
A third way to say it-- See if
you can finish this sentence.
This is for the
independent, the good guys.
If I put those five vectors
into a five by five matrix,
that matrix will
be... invertible.
That matrix will be invertible.
So an invertible matrix
is one with a basis
sitting in its columns.
It's a transform that
has an inverse transform.
This matrix is not invertible,
those three vectors
are not a basis.
Their combinations
are only in a plane.
By the way, a plane
as a subspace.
A plane would be a
typical subspace.
It's like fill it out.
You took all the combinations,
you did your job,
but in that case the whole space
would count as a subspace too.
That's the way
you get subspaces,
by taking all combinations.
Okay, now I'm even going to
push you one more step and then
this example is complete.
Can you tell me what
vectors do you get?
All combinations of u, v, w.
Let me try to write something.
This gives only a plane.
Because we've got two
independent vectors but not
the third.
Okay.
I don't know if I
should even ask.
Do we know an equation
for that plane?
Well I think we do if we
think about it correctly.
All combinations of u, v, w* is
the same as saying all vectors
C times x, right?
Do you agree that those two
are exactly the same thing?
This is the key,
because we're moving up
to vectors, combinations,
and now comes subspaces.
If I take all
combinations of u, v, w*,
I say that that's the same
as all vectors C times x,
why's that?
It's what I said in the very
first sentence at 4 o'clock.
The combinations of u, v,
w*, how do I produce them?
I create the matrix
with those columns.
I multiply them by x's, and
I get all the combinations.
And this is just C times x.
So what I've said there
is just another way
of saying how does matrix
multiplication work.
Put the guys in its columns
and multiply by a vector.
So we're getting all
vectors C times x,
and now I was going to stretch
it that little bit further.
Can we describe
what vectors we get?
So that's my question.
What b's -- so this is b =
[b 1,  b 2, b 3] -- do we get?
We don't get them all.
Right, we don't get them all.
That's the trouble with C.
We only get a plane of them.
And now can you
tell me which b's
we do get when we look at all
combinations of these three
dependent vectors.
Well we've done a lot today.
Let me just tell you the
answer because it's here.
The b's have to add to zero.
That's the equation that
the b's have to satisfy.
Because when we wrote out Cx
we noticed that the components
always added to zero.
Which b's do we get?
We get the ones where the
components add to zero.
In other words that's the
equation of the plane,
you could say.
Yeah.
Actually that's a good
way to look at it.
All these vectors
are on the plane.
Do the components
of u add to zero?
Look at u.
Yes.
Do the components
of v add to zero?
Yes.
Add them up.
Do the components of w*, now
that you've fixed it correctly,
do they add to zero?
Yes.
So all the combinations
will add to zero.
That's the plane.
You see there are so many
different ways to see,
and none of this is
difficult, but it's
coming fast because we're
seeing the same thing
in different languages.
We're seeing it geometrically
in a picture of a plane.
We're seeing it as a
combination of vectors.
multiplication by a matrix.
And we saw it sort
of here by operation,
operating and simplifying,
and getting the key fact out
of the equations.
Well, okay.
I wanted to give you this
example, the two examples,
because they bring out
so many of the key ideas.
The key idea of a subspace.
Shall I just say a little
about what that word means?
A subspace.
What's a subspace?
Well, what's a vector
space first of all?
A vector space is
a bunch of vectors.
And the rule is you
have to be able to take
their combinations.
That what linear algebra does.
Takes combinations.
So a vector space is one where
you take all combinations.
So if I only took just this
triangle that would not
be a subspace because one
combination would be 2u
and it would be out
of the triangle.
So a subspace, just
think of it as a plane,
but then of course it could
be in higher dimensions.
You know it could be a
7-dimensional subspace
inside a 15-dimensional space.
And I don't know if you're good
at visualizing that, I'm not.
Never mind.
You you've got seven
vectors, you think okay,
their combinations give us
seven-dimensional subspace.
Each factor has 15 components.
No problem.
I mean no problem
for MATLAB certainly.
It's got what, a matrix
with a 105 entries.
It deals with that instantly.
Okay, so a subspace is like a
vector space inside a bigger
one.
That's why the prefix
"sub-" is there.
Right?
And mathematics always counts
the biggest possibility too,
which would be the whole space.
And what's the smallest?
So what's the smallest
subspace of R^3?
So I have 3-dimensional
space-- you can tell me all
the subspaces of R^3.
So there is one, a plane.
Yeah, tell me all
the subspaces of R^3.
And then you'll have
that word kind of down.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: A line.
So planes and lines,
those you could say,
the real, the proper subspaces.
The best, the right ones.
But there are a couple more
possibilities which are?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: A point.
Which point?
The origin.
Only the origin.
Because if you tried to say that
point was a subspace, no way.
Why not?
Because I wouldn't
be able to multiply
that vector by five and I
would be away from the point.
But the zero subspace,
the really small subspace
that just has the zero vector,
it's got one vector in it.
Not empty.
It's got that one
point but that's all.
Okay, so planes,
lines, the origin,
and then the other possibility
for a subspaces is?
The whole space.
Right.
So the dimensions could be
three for the whole space,
two for a plane, one for
a line, zero for a point.
It just kicks together.
How are we for time?
Maybe I went more than half, but
now is a chance to just ask me,
if you want to, like
anything about the course.
Is at all linear algebra?
No.
But I think I can't do
anything more helpful to you
then to for you
to begin to see--
when you look at a matrix,
begin to see what is it doing.
What is it about.
Right, and of course
matrices can be rectangular.
So I'll give you a
hint about what's
coming in the course itself.
We'll have rectangular
matrices A, okay.
They're not invertible.
They're taking
seven-dimensional space
to three-dimensional
space or something.
You can't invert that.
What comes up every time-- I
sort of got the idea finally.
Every time I see a rectangular
matrix, maybe seven by three,
that would be seven
rows by three columns.
Then what comes up with
a rectangular matrix
A is sooner or later A
transpose sticks its nose in
and multiplies that A. And we
couldn't do it for our A here.
Actually if I did it for
that original matrix A
I would get something
you'd recognize.
What I want to say is
that the course focuses
on A transpose A. I'll just
say now that that matrix always
comes out square, because this
would be three times seven
times seven times three, so
this would be three by three,
and it always comes
out symmetric.
That's the nice thing.
And even more.
We'll see more.
That's like a hint.
Watch for A transpose
A. And watch for it
in applications of all kinds.
In networks an A
will be associated
with Kirchhoff's voltage
law, and A transpose
with Kirchhoff's current law.
They just teamed up together.
We'll see more.
Alright now let me give you
a chance to ask any question.
Whatever.
Homework.
Did I mention homework?
You may have said
that's a crazy homework
to say three problems 1.1.
I've never done this
before so essentially you
can get away with
anything this week,
and indefinitely actually.
How many are-- Is this the
first day of MIT classes?
Oh wow.
Okay.
Well, welcome to MIT.
I hope you like it.
It's not so high
pressure or whatever
is associated with MIT.
It's kind of tolerant.
If my advisees ask for
something I always say yes.
It's easier that way.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER].
PROFESSOR STRANG: And
let me just again--
and I'll say it
often and in private.
This is like a grown-up course.
I'm figuring you're
here to learn,
so it's not my job to force it.
My job is to help it, and
hope this is some help.